woman will never fully comprehend man
just as man will never fully comprehend
women we are made for each other and yet
we are Mysteries to each other that's
the essence of Romance the difference
though is that man knows he cannot
understand woman and he's okay with that
woman in fact becomes very frustrated by
just how okay with it he is so you know
she'll say something cryptic and out of
context to him and he'll have no idea
what she's talking about but he'll just
go oh okay and then get back to what
he's doing and she'll stand there
stunned and say well aren't you going to
ask me what I'm talking about and he'll
say okay yeah what were you talking
about and he'll just hope it isn't a
long story but it always is on the flip
side man can say nothing at all he can
simply walk into the room with a
slightly abnormal facial expression and
woman will start interrogating and
waterboarding him to extract every last
piece of information she can about this
facial expression what are you thinking
she'll ask and she won't accept it when
he says nothing even if that really is
the answer